let's take a look at the downward spiral
of the children of trump over the last
few days since we learned of the Trump
indictment we are not going to be
talking about Ivanka here Ivanka just
put out kind of a very short statement
on Instagram saying she's heard from
people all over the political Spectrum
concerned about what's going on very
very vague Ivanka does seem to be
wanting to stay far from politics after
the disaster of her first four years of
involvement in politics we then go to
Donald Trump Jr who now has a show on
Rumble and the downward spiral really
continues it's it's actually kind of
getting sad and listen I'm sure it is
very difficult for your father to be
indicted I'm sure it is also it's not
you know we know that Trump doesn't seem
necessarily to be the biggest fan of his
adult male children but that's another
story anyway here is Don Jr just
dissembling this is clearly an attempt
to intimidate a journalist and yet the
rest of Journalism the rest of the media
strangely silent
guys listen Maybe coincidence has
happened but not anymore in 2023 I don't
believe in this much coincidence and if
you've been watching literally anything
for like the last six years you
shouldn't either the fact that the IRS
showed up at Matt taibi's house on the
same day that he testified before
Congress and their new committee
investigating the weaponization of the
federal government is
ironic
suspicious it's absolutely insane okay
that's how these opening statement on
the Twitter files Twitter Facebook
Google and other companies developed a
formal system for taking in moderation
requests from every corner of government
FBI DHS HHS DOD the global engagement
Center etc etc that's his opening line
and we think that it's a coincidence
that the IRS knocks on his door that day
all right so what this all has to do
with Donald Trump is unclear why
Junior's eyes are almost completely
swollen shut we don't know that seems to
be similar to his own dad and here is
Donald Trump Jr during his Rumble show
um really just furious about this entire
thing I was proven even more right than
I would have ever imagined because is
that even possible that nobody's been
more right than Don Jr about everything
I guess apparently you know Soros to
Batman Manhattan district attorney Alvin
Bragg okay and again I don't know why he
says sore roast backed but if he means
George sorospact we've looked at this in
detail remember George Soros funds
hundreds of programs one of the programs
George Soros funds is a pack that helps
to get DA's elected one of the DA's that
was helped buy that pack is Alvin Bragg
there has never been any contact between
Alvin Alvin Bragg and George Soros there
has never been any communication one way
or the other about a trump investigation
that's the connection that they're
talking about they want you to think
Soros is calling Alvin Bragg and saying
indict Trump is actually indicting my
father so let's be clear folks yeah this
is
like communist level this is stuff that
would make Mao
Stalin
uh Pol Pot it would make them blush it's
so flagrant it's so crazed when even
like the radical leftists of the
Washington Post are out there saying
it's not really based on facts it's not
really based on the lot not really based
in reality but it's a hundred percent
based on politics when your enemies are
saying that
it's got to tell you everything you need
to know right now about where we are as
a country yeah where we are is it turns
out that the one-man crime spree that
was Donald Trump isn't above the law
just because he was President that's
what it tells us and that is a good
thing